nowhere in the Bible does it say You
must believe that Jesus Christ is Yahweh
is God himself God Almighty himself says
that you must confess that Jesus is the
Messiah the Christ the son of God
[Music]
that was young Don for those of you who
do not know young Don is a content
creator with a big channel here on
YouTube
um he has 360
000 subscribers he gets over a thousand
people to watch while he's live
streaming he's a streamer uh and so he
has a pretty big Channel
um why he's relevant right now in this
conversation to this video is he
announced about uh almost a year ago
about 10 months ago not even a full year
that he has come to Christianity
um and the reasons why he came to
Christianity and he announced the Lord
as a savior and
claimed to be a Christian now
this is why this is troubling because
just yesterday from the day of this
stream
he went live on YouTube with almost a
thousand people watching and denounced
the Trinity the truth the fact of the
matter is I still believe that Jesus
came from the father and not in some
metaphorical weird mysterious way to
where he in some way always existed
alongside the father while still coming
from the father being born of the father
eternally begotten is how the Catholics
would put it I was like yeah this does
this is just not had enough for me it's
just not making sense
him being a new Christian as you guys
see from this this was a part of the
stream if you guys want to check out his
full stream three hours go check it out
now I want to start by saying this this
is not a bashing video this is not a
video to attack young Don this is not a
video to discourage him to put him down
in any way shape and form in fact I
would love to have a conversation with
you young Don I hope and pray that this
video reaches you and so that we can
connect with each other and hopefully
discuss the scriptures because I really
believe that if we have a conversation
I'll be able to hopefully by God's will
bring some light to these verses that
you're bringing up okay
um but with that said uh there's
something that I want to touch on here
and that is the importance of Doctrine
and sound Doctrine the importance of
community young Don is a lone wolf out
there he's a new Christian or you know
claiming to be a new Christian
um and who is out already doing videos
and live streams and addressing deep
topics on salvation and the doctrine of
God and things of this nature instead of
taking the time to sit and learn these
subjects go and develop yourself in the
knowledge of these subjects and ask
these questions with people who know
better with uh with with with pastors
and Bishops and overseers instead you're
doing this on your own which is not wise
at all matter of fact Proverbs talks
about how the wise man seeks counsel and
surrounds himself with counsel but right
now you're doing it on your own and it's
not good because now you're out here and
you're susceptible to false teaching and
heresy the Bible has these things that
it pays close attention to that it
repeats over and over again like for
example sexual immorality it warns
repeatedly all over the Bible over and
over again against the dangers of sexual
immorality fleeing from it avoid it with
all cause die to your flesh when it
comes to sexual morality just just run
from it with with all your might if you
can run from sexual immorality kill it
in your body in your flesh right that's
what the Bible repeatedly warns us about
but there's also something else that it
repeatedly warns us about and that is
false Doctrine and false teaching
strange teaching strange Doctrine and a
false gospel it repeatedly warns the
Believers against false Doctrine and
false preachers who will come up and
start teaching strange Doctrine
especially to new Believers in fact we
go to Galatians chapter one watch what
Paul says to the people in galatia he
starts off as saying in verse six I am
astonished that you are so quickly
deserting him who called you in the
grace of Christ and are turning to a
different gospel
not that there is another one but there
are some who trouble you and want to
distort the gospel of Christ so Paul is
sitting here he's surprised he's
flabbergasted I was just with you guys I
go away and you guys are so quickly
deserting the gospel that you received
from these false teachers he continues
but even if we or an angel from heaven
should preach to you a gospel contrary
to the one we preach to you let him be
accursed as we have said before so now I
say again if anyone is preaching to you
a gospel contrary to the one you
received let him be accursed this is all
throughout the scriptures and the fact
if we go to Second Peter chapter 2 verse
1 he also warns against false teachers
and false Doctrine watch this but false
prophets also arose among the people
just as there will be false teachers
among you who will secretly bring in
destructive heresies even denying the
master who brought who bought them
bringing upon themselves a swift
destruction Hebrews chapter 13 verse 9
do not be led Away by diverse and
strange teachings
you guys catching it it's a pattern here
it's a continuous warning against false
teachings and false Doctrine because
that's dangerous it repeats this Romans
chapter 16 verses 17 to 18 says I appeal
to you Brothers to watch out for those
who cause divisions and create obstacles
contrary to the doctrine that you have
been taught
avoid them for such persons do not serve
our Lord Christ but their own appetites
and by smooth talk and flattery they
deceive the hearts of the naive it is so
important that you guys as Christians as
Believers me myself I'm included
especially when we're new to this when
we're new to the walk that we surround
ourselves with believers who are sound
in the faith who rightly divide the word
of Truth and who grow Us in development
in our spiritual walk we cannot be alone
out here because we happen to be part of
the naive group the group that's
susceptible to false Doctrine this is
actually in fact the reason why God has
has given us pastors and preachers and
teachers prophets and apostles in fact
Ephesians 4 it breaks this down starting
at verse 11 it says this and he gave the
apostles the prophets the evangelists
the shepherd words and teachers to equip
the Saints for the work of Ministry for
building the body of Christ until we all
attain the to the unity of the faith and
of the knowledge of the Son of God to
mature manhood to the measure of the
stature of the fullness of Christ so
that we may no longer be children
tossed to and fro by the waves and
carried about by every wind of Doctrine
by human cunning by craftiness and
deceitful schemes and you'll notice if
you go check out his his uh his stream
he talks about how he's going uh from
one idea to the next from one Doctrine
to the other is Jesus uncreated is he
not as Eternal and things of this nature
being swayed and moved by every wave of
Doctrine the Bible warns against this
and actually has provided ways that we
can avoid this danger and so I continue
to study and you know there was a point
in time where I was like oh maybe Jesus
didn't pre-exist the world right maybe
using Eternal by surrounding us with
sound people with sound Doctrine and
spending time with the Lord instead of
going out there on our own even Paul
himself Paul went to Peter James and
John to affirm the Revelation that he
received to make sure that he was wasn't
preaching and running in vain so we all
need that confirmation we all need to be
led by the spirit and be surrounded by
the church with that being said you guys
want to see the Bible interpret the
Bible nowhere in the Bible does it say
You must believe that Jesus Christ is
Yahweh is God himself does the bible
teach that you must believe that he is
God Almighty Yahweh In the Flesh in
order to be saved
well Jesus answers this question in John
chapter 8 verse 24 he says I told you
that you will die in your sins unless
you believe that I am he you will die in
your sins now why is this significant
Jesus claiming the phrase of himself I
am he why would this matter to the Jews
because claiming to be God that means
nothing just saying I am God that means
anybody was doing everybody and their
mama was doing that but claiming to be
Yahweh now that holds weight to the Jews
and so Jesus shows you that there's
levels to this when we go to the Hebrew
scriptures in Isaiah chapter 41 verse 4
it reads I the Lord the first and the
last I am he
Isaiah 43 10 that you may know and
believe that I am he 46 4 even to your
old age I am he Isaiah 48 12 listen to
me Jacob Israel whom I have called I am
he the first and the last so when Jesus
says that I am he and you will die in
your sins unless you believe that I am
he he's claiming to be Yahweh of the Old
Testament who says the exact same thing
to the Israelites that I am doing this
so that you may know and believe that I
am he and if you don't you will die in
your sins does that make sense
so yes according to the scriptures
according to Jesus unless you believe
that he is Yahweh God In the Flesh God
Almighty the true God then you will die
in your sins you have a false gospel and
you have a false Christ a creature who
cannot save you but if you do not have
the right teaching then you'll end up
saying stuff like this
calls him his father
to be someone's father it means you must
exist before your son
it's that simple it is that simple in
order to be the father actually it's not
that you exist before your son but that
you beget a son you're not a father
unless you have a son my father has been
a father for only 28 years even though
he's lived longer than 28 years he's
been a he became a father when I was
born but God has always been the father
he's always been the heavenly father so
if he's always been the father then he's
always had the son there is not a point
in time where God the Father became the
father he's always been the Father which
means that there's not a point in time
where he didn't have a son Christ has
always been there from the beginning as
the son with the father it's that simple
which would also lead us into the next
objection look at this
who has delivered us from the power of
darkness and has translated us into the
kingdom of his dear son in whom we have
Redemption through his blood even the
Forgiveness of sins who is the image of
the invisible God the firstborn of every
creature now think about that he is the
firstborn of every creature what does
this mean for him to be the firstborn of
a set it means he needs to be a part of
that set guys if you guys want to check
out a video where I debunk this argument
with Jehovah's Witnesses live in their
face
um you can check out this video right
here go to it we literally addressed
this subject here now I want you guys to
notice something notice how and guys go
check out his stream you guys can go see
it it's three hours long go see her you
can see the context he never quoted the
next verse
he never quoted the next verse that
tells him why Paul is calling Jesus the
firstborn of all creation
and I have some uh I have my reasons why
I think that is I think it's because he
doesn't know to do that I don't think he
knows to read in context or how to read
the Bible in its context I don't think
he knows how to do that he's fresh he's
new to this this is not a bashing this
is just my observation and so this is
why it's important it is so important
for you to just sit and humble yourself
man you gotta humble yourself before
you're going up live and and rushing to
spread your ideas and these false
doctrines because now you are you you
can you can be humiliated even though
that's not the purpose of these things
but you can come out and you it does
it's not a good look it's not a good
look if we read the next verse of
Colossians it tells us why Jesus is
called the firstborn of all creation
number one here's a fun fact firstborn
doesn't always mean literally firstborn
firstborn can literally mean the
firstborn the first thing the oldest
thing or it can be a position of
preeminence a position of Supremacy and
so the context tells you what firstborn
means right so check this out Colossians
chapter one after we have read in verse
15 that he is the image of the invisible
God the firstborn of all creation then
goes on and says this in verse 16. for
by him all things were created in heaven
on Earth visible and invisible whether
Thrones or dominions or rulers or
authorities all things were created
through him and for him and he is before
all things and in him all things hold
together and he is the head of the body
the church he is the beginning the
firstborn of the Dead that in everything
he might be
preeminent so in what way is Jesus the
firstborn of all creation he's
preeminent over all creation notice how
he's not a part of that Set Young Don
because it's by him that all things were
created that excludes himself he himself
was not created he's the one who created
all things and is before all things in
him all things hold together all right
so this is insane that he's part of
creation it's saying he's above it and
John chapter 1 helps this point you
mentioned this in your in your stream
well you didn't go over but you briefly
mentioned it watch this John chapter 1
verse 1-3 in the beginning was the word
and the Word was with God and the Word
was God he was in the beginning with God
all things were made through him and
without him was not anything made that
was made do you guys see that that
without him nothing came into existence
all things that came into existence came
into existence through Jesus
that means Jesus had to already exist
that means Jesus never came into
existence he's not part of that but
that's how you rightly divide the
scripture the scripture is emphatically
clear that Jesus is eternal he's
infinite never had a beginning never has
an end and has always existed alongside
the father creating the world sustaining
the world and holding it up by the word
of his power watch this what we get in
Hebrews chapter one long ago at many
times and in many ways God spoke to our
fathers by the prophets but in these
last days he has spoken to us by his son
whom he appointed the heir of all things
through whom he also created the world
he is the radiance of the glory of God
and the exact imprint of his nature and
he upholds the universe by the word of
his power after making purifications of
for sins he has sat down at the right
hand of the Majesty on high very clear
not only has the sun always been there
but the son is the one by whom he
sustains the universe all of creation
all of existence is sustained by the
word of the son and he is the radiance
of the glory of God is God's glory
finite no
God's glory is infinite and Jesus is the
radiance of that infinite Glory
and the exact imprint of his nature so
how can you make the conclusion that
Jesus is a creature no creature ha is
the imprint of the nature of God having
the nature of God I was like yeah this
does this is just not adding up for me
it's just not making sense so you see
how he sits at the right hand of majesty
ruling with God the Father which brings
us to our next objection here who does
Jesus pray to he tells us who to pray to
therefore you should pray like this Our
Father in Heaven your name be honored as
holy does your kingdom come it is the
Father's Kingdom your will be done Jesus
says for the Gentile World eagerly seeks
all these things and your father knows
that you need them but seek his kingdom
now whose kingdom is it again this is
what happens when you do not know how to
rightly divide the scriptures if you
guys know to see he's asking see whose
kingdom is it it's God the father's
Kingdom but wasn't it him who earlier
read that it was actually also the
kingdom of his son yeah I'll I'll let
the footage be let the receipts talk who
has delivered us from the power of
darkness and has translated us into the
kingdom of his daresome now whose
kingdom is it into the kingdom of his
darese the gospels of the kingdom of God
to God's kingdom Jesus does not call it
our King into the kingdom of his dare so
also when we go and look at John chapter
18 when Jesus is being questioned by
Pilate he says that my kingdom is not of
this world whose kingdom is it my
kingdom is not of this world so where
young Don is Jesus's Kingdom maybe in
heaven maybe the Kingdom of Heaven is
his kingdom along with the father's
Kingdom the father's kingdom is the
son's Kingdom it's not either or it's
both and but you guys you would know
this if you knew how to rightly divide
the scriptures and then you ask who does
Jesus pray to of course he's
communicating with the Father prayer is
just communication Jesus was with the
father from eternity's past
communicating fellowshipping with the
father and the spirit always from
eternity
so why would it change when he now comes
down to earth he's going to stop talking
to the father stop communicating with
him now now that he's human know he
doesn't become an atheist he's going to
continue that communication in prayer
but that's not all though Jesus also
tells us that we can pray to him in John
chapter 14 verses 12 to 14. Jesus says
when he's going to the father that we
can ask anything in his name and he'll
do it he says ask me anything in my name
and I will do it
so Jesus says that we can also pray to
him we can address him
now think about this young Don and
everyone listening for Jesus to be able
to hear all the prayers of the Saints
all over the place all over the world
what kind of attribute would he have to
have in order to be able to hear and
know who's praying and know what they're
we're praying for what kind of attribute
would he have to have he would have to
be all-knowing he'll also have to be
omnipresent to be able to answer every
request wherever we are millions and
billions of us on the planet at the same
time omnipresent
all-knowing omnipresent and then what
type of attribute would Jesus have to
have in order to be able to answer any
request of us ask me anything in my name
and I will do it for him to be able to
do anything we ask what attribute does
he have to have omnipotence all powerful
so with these verses alone we see that
Jesus is all-knowing
omnipresent
not limited to space and time
and he's all-powerful able to answer and
Grant our requests whatever it is
wherever we are at whatever time it
doesn't matter
these are the attributes of God and this
is the god that you're denying you never
knew him and before you got to know him
you left him and now you're rejecting
him you're rejecting the master who
bought you so I'm saying this with love
I'm saying this to encourage you bro
dive deep into your word dive deep into
your scriptures and humble yourself if
you're bold enough to be able to come on
a live stream and talk about these type
of things these views your views these
beliefs then you should be able to give
an answer and a reason for why you
believe and that's biblical logic
logic
thank you